for the first time we are seeing real
world evidence of how well one hpv
vaccine can prevent one of the most
common cancers in women
researchers are calling these results
historic more than 90 percent of
cervical cancers are caused by hpv
the uk study shows an 87 decrease that's
right decrease in the rate of cervical
cancer in women who are vaccinated
against hpv between the ages of 12 and
13 that's compared to an unvaccinated
group the research was published in the
lancet the cbs news chief medical
correspondent that's dr john lepuc joins
us now at the table john it's so good to
see you because i know you've been
talking about this for a very very long
time i'm curious about what your
reaction was when you heard this news
seems like a very big deal it is this
was great news you know this was one of
the very first stories i i did back in
2006 when i first came to cbs news was
the fda approval of this vaccine at that
point it was a hypothesis we knew that
more than 90 of cervical cancers are
caused by the hpv virus and the question
is well okay it makes sense if you
prevent that infection you should
prevent cervical cancer but we didn't
know as a hypothesis now we know
absolutely it does and i remember it was
controversial at the time there was a
big discussion around whether or not it
should be given and what age and now the
recommendation is for for girls as young
as nine why start so early and that does
seem very early very young very very
good question there are two very good
reasons one is this is not a treatment
it's a prevention it only works if you
prevent it so of course you want to give
the vaccine before somebody can be
sexually active the other one that's not
so intuitively obvious is that when you
give it at a younger age it actually
works better it elicits a stronger
immune response so those are the two
reasons okay but as a parent of a
daughter who is 11 years old i'm
thinking to myself well this is an
infection that she might not get so why
should i give my daughter this hpv
vaccine you may think she may not get it
but about more than 85 percent of
americans who are sexually active get it
it's a very common easily transmitted uh
infection right it's out there it's not
for sure and it's not just girls it's
boys too so this is now boys aren't in
this conversation though
i was gonna drag them in myself right
yeah absolutely i had boys get it yes
it's recommended for boys boys not only
can give it to the girls so just there's
an ethical reason to try to reduce it
and prevent that that
mo the mode of transportation of
infection right but also guys can
actually get infected themselves and
develop these cancers guys can get
cancer of the throat of the tongue of
the genitals of the anus and those areas
of the body can also happen you can get
cancers there in men and in women wow so
finally you know we have all these
vaccines talk of vaccines that can
prevent all these deadly childhood
illnesses we have a vaccine that can
prevent cancer you just mentioned the
word sexually active does it apply if
you're sexually active is that what
you're talking about well the way this
is uh spread is through sexual activity
and it's actually in the skin so you
know if you wear a condom it can give
you some protection but it's actually
skin-to-skin contact so it doesn't give
you perfect protection that's why it's
so easy to spread it and it can be
spread by all sorts of sexual roots but
that's why when you hear a nine-year-old
girl's getting it you just don't think
of nine-year-olds that's actually
actually they're not sexually active but
you got to give them the connection
or they are sexually active
preventing it from preventive measures
once they get the infection it's not a
treatment you have to give them a
vaccine so that when they get exposed
they then don't develop the infection i
guess that also explains the 13-year lag
between when the shot was initially
given and then these results uh they're
out of the uk is there a similar study
coming here in this country you know
we've said little studies that have
suggested this is the biggest one and
it's really great to see that finally we
have the data to say this works and it's
not probably going to work just for
cervical cancer but for the other
cancers that i mentioned that are also
associated with hpv it's still a
voluntary thing at the moment it's
voluntary yes you're endorsing it right
i totally endorse it all right
enthusiastically all right all right dr
john lapook thank you very much